the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video in this
video i want to go over another one of
variety's articles from their website in
this article we found out what actor
steve tousant had to say about the fan's
backlash regarding his character as i'm
sure most of you already know by now
there's still a lot of a song of ice and
fire fans who are very upset with hbo
for hiring a black man as laura corliss
velaryon as a matter of fact they've
been angry with this ever since hbo
officially announced who landed the role
as the legendary sea snake
well in this new article house of the
dragons star steve dusant had a few
words for the fire and blood readers who
can't stomach the fact that hbo hired
him instead of a white man now although
he did not have a lot to say on the
matter i still want to show all of you
what was actually said let's have a look
at their article now it says house of
the dragon star steve toussaint spoke
out against a backlash from some readers
who criticized his casting as famed
sailor lorcorlus velaryon aka the sea
snake
this outrage stems from the fact that
this character the husband of rhaenys
targaryen is not a black man in george r
martin's novel fire and blood which is
what the game of thrones series is based
on the actor goes on to say as we spoke
about yesterday other than certain fans
thoughts about someone who looks like me
playing this part it hasn't really
affected the role in my experience on
the job with my fellow actors as i've
said before there are a song of ice and
fire fans outside who find it a little
hard to stomach that someone who looks
like me would be lord cordless velaryon
however that's an issue they have to
deal with and i don't have to the issue
for me is always the same i just have to
say the lines convincingly and avoid
bumping into the furniture now as you
all know george rr martin is working
directly with hbo and house of the
dragon showrunners ryan condell and
miguel sapochnick he has been working
with them on this new show every step of
the way since house of the dragons
inception now the way i see it is if the
author himself doesn't mind that a black
man is stepping into the shoes of lord
corliss velaryon then i don't see how
any of the fans should have something to
say about it the author the creator of a
song of ice and fire doesn't mind how
they've gone in this direction
for all we know it might have even been
george rr martin who went to hbo and
said they should make lorcorlos valeria
on a black man now let's be honest here
none of us actually know what's
happening behind the scenes unless
someone comes out and says otherwise
most of us should already know what
george rr martin will do if he's very
unhappy with how they're handling one of
his characters during the making of game
of thrones writers david and dan made so
many different additions or should i say
subtractions to the character of jane
westerling he actually made them switch
her entire name to something else
because he wasn't liking what they had
done
in george rr martin's novels rob stark
got married to jane westerling but in
game of thrones her name was talisa he
made them do this because he did not
want his fans thinking they were the
same characters now don't you think he
would do the same thing to lure corliss
velaryon if he actually didn't like this
idea i think this is another good sign
that he actually signs off on what
they've done otherwise he might not go
by the same name now if you ask me i
actually like the addition because it
does make him stand out from the rest
which makes him even more interesting
not only that but i even think he is the
most badass looking character on the
show i'm very excited to see what he
will do
now obviously i've only seen a few
seconds of him on the screen in each of
the teasers and trailers but it already
looks like he's done an amazing job i
hope that at least some of you will
begin to see it this way as well i think
he will win over some of the naysayers
if they at least give the man a damn
chance leave me some of your thoughts
down below i'm always interested in
hearing what you have to say as always i
want to thank everyone for stopping by
and watching the short update video i
hope all of you will subscribe so you
can be the first to know whenever i drop
a new video there are a lot more heading
your way for now have a great day
everyone i will see you again very soon
bye
you